ています
い
あー寒いんですよ
寒いせずボケがねぇ
ブーブー not 説明させていただくとあーまず
帰ってきてまず大今度友達とあー海かあったんですよパーマーサーファー seasar
外観ですよそう
ボランティア
のん
me
スラッシャーこれ
nc の母 noa ビルできるじゃカラー
大里3人ですなーをすごいことですねー
で面白いかとして
ああああああ
思って始めた
味らしいだよ
妻が帰ってきたんでー
6使う0封ため旅をしたいと思います
10時に終わるって言われたんでジャンに見舞いに来てって言ったんですけど
ちょっと友達とカラオケに行っちゃってああ
me
うん失格迎えに来てもらったんですけど書いた抹茶ってすごい迷惑かけちゃったんです
よ
なんで今ですねちょうど
4日
新幹線デー
主月に乗ってうん
新幹線の始発に乗って
家まで歩いて帰るということなんですけど
その距離なんとですねー
どんぐらいだろう
多分だいたい歩いたら1時間はかかるととの雪なら
こらああ
過ごす除雪車ですよこれがああ
ですよこれ
っていう感じなんで
頑張って家まで
帰ろうと思います
me
ああああああ
母さん父さん米な友達と遊びたかった久しぶりに会った
正月のバイトばったりで海に向かったからもうすごい遊びたかったんですよ友達と地元
の
で久しぶりに滑りに遊べて楽しかったね
その罰だしてね
家までん
今で歩いて帰ります
朝だけ持ち替えしよう
じゃん
n
ni
ん
もうなんか北海道食ねー
この日
この第一の広がり方だ